*music*
Good morning Hank, it's Sunday; it's news day.
I don't know if this is true for you, but for me, at any one time, I'm able to follow about 6 news stories.
So right now, I've got the economic crisis, I've got Iraq,
I've got Pakistan,
and then I've got the Craigslist killer,
and then fifth: I have a pretty good handle on North Korea,
and then lastly, of course, I've been closely following the breakup of Lindsay Lohan and Samantha
I-don't-know-your-last-name-and-wish-I-didn't-know-your-first-name.
So, admittedly, Hank, six news stories isn't a lot,
but I feel like a pretty well informed citizen!
But then along comes a news story like Sri Lanka
and I'm like "Oh, there's been a civil war going on?"
"Oh, for thirty years?"
Now Hank, I'm not here to yell at people
about not paying attention to the extremely serious situation in Sri Lanka,
because it's not your fault for
not paying attention to it, because it's complicated
aaand no one has ever explained it to you
while rubbing Creamy peanut butter on his face.
Yes, Hank, I know how to get people
to pay attention to serious international news stories...
Peanut Butter Face!
Ok Hank, so pop quiz:
What religion are the people
who invented both contemporary suicide bombings
and the suicide vest?
That's right Hank, they're Hindus.
Also, some are Christian,
uummm,
and they're not terribly religious.
I'm referring, of course, to the Tamil Tigers,
the seperatist group
currently in Sri Lanka
getting the crap bombed out of them
by the Sri Lankan government.
I don't know why I'm applying the peanut butter only to
the places where I would shave.
So Hank, to understand the Tamil Tigers
we actually have to go back to 1956.
Sri Lanka had just gained its independence a few years before
and the majority Buddhist Sinhalese ethnic group
decided that
Sinhalese should be the only language in all of Sri Lanka
and that Buddhism should be the official religion.
Well Hank, I'm sure I don't need to tell you how
the Tamil minority felt about that happening...
they didn't like it!
So these tensions simmer for decades
and finally in 1983
war breaks out.
A group called the Tamil Tigers is fighting for
an independent Tamil state in the northern east of Sri Lanka
while the Sri Lankan government is fighting to keep the island a single country.
And it's a difficult thing Hank,
because you can't have every single ethnic group that
wants its own country having its own country.
On the other hand,
the government has never treated the Tamil people equally or fairly in Sri Lanka.
Over the years, the war has killed more than 80,000 people
and there are really no good guys in this war.
The Sri Lankan government is inarguably to blame
for the disappearance of many Tamils.
And the Tamil Tigers, aside from being a terrorist organisation
according to a long list of countries,
are also famous not only for their suicide bombings
but also for their recruitment of child soldiers.
In 2002, after almost 20 years of this on-again-off-again civil war,
the Sri Lankan government and the Tamil Tigers finally signed a ceasefire.
And everyone was so relieved
and so excited
and there was some thought that, eventually, like,
the Tamil majority part of Sri Lanka might have some measure of autonomy,
but then in the beginning of this year the war erupted again
and now the Tamil Tigers are on the run
and they control very little territory
and the Sri Lankan government has them surrounded
and is basically just trying to pound them into submission.
But as is the nature of rebel groups,
particularly, like, ones that are
suicidally bent on independence,
there is not really any "winning".
But, Hank, the worst part of the story is that
in the last 3 months
the UN estimates that more than 6,000 civilians
have been killed, either by the government or by the Tamil Tigers.
And, Hank, when there are no obvious candidates
for the Evil Baby Orphanage
it's really easy for the international community
just to get bored and stop watching.
We like to follow news stories that make sense,
and when news stories ask us to think hard
and make difficult judgements about ambiguous situations
we tend to,
you know,
only pay attention to them when someone is slathered in peanut butter
which, by the way, if you are wondering, is really uncomfortable.
My face wants to sweat but it can't.
So Hank, that's my Peanut Butter Face introduction
to the civil war currently raging in Sri Lanka.
Let's hope for an immediate ceasefire
so we can have these insanely complicated political discussions
without killing thousands of people...
Just these few seconds! Just a- oohhh.
Hank, when Willy sleeps,
he dreams of a world in which all people have Peanut Butter Face.